>> SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE RACE
IN FLORIDA, RON DeSANTIS RUNNING
FOR REELECTION ON TUESDAY FOR
GOVERNOR.
HIS CAMPAIGN RELEASED AN AD HOW
GOD PICKED A FIGHTER TO BECOME
FLORIDA'S GOVERNOR.
IT IS ODD.
LISTEN.
>> AND ON THE 8th DAY GOD LOOKED
DOWN ON HIS PLANNED PARADISE AND
SAID I NEED A PROTECTOR.
SO GOD MADE A FIGHTER.
>> THE AD INVOKES GOD'S NAME TEN
TIMES IN 96 SECONDS.
DeSANTIS IS NEVER MENTIONED BUT
AS THE WORD GOD IS SAID, YOU
KEEP SEEING THESE IMAGES OF
DeSANTIS.
WHAT DO YOU -- WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
LIKE I SAID, ODD.
I MEAN, IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK IF
YOU'RE GOING TO COIN A PHRASE,
YOU MIGHT SAY THE AD IS IT IS
QUITE REMARKABLE.
ONE THING TO BE ENDORSED BY LIZ
CHENEY.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO BE
ENDORSED BY GOD AND I LOVE THE
VOICE FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER, IT
SOUNDS LIKE PAL UL HARVEY, THE
GREAT RADIO ANNOUNCER.
I'M SURE IT WILL PLAY TO A
CERTAIN AUDIENCE.
I'M SURE A LOT OF CHRISTIAN
EVANGELICALS BUT TO SAY GOD
CREATED A FIGHTER OVER AND OVER
AND TO CONTINUE TO SHOW PICTURES
OF THE GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS IS
AS YOU SAY CURIOUS.
>> IT IS AMAZING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE ANYBODY WOULD BE
COMFORTABLE ABOUT SUCH A THING
APPEARING ABOUT THEM ON
TELEVISION BUT I SUPPOSE THAT IS
WHAT IT TAKES HAVE TO SEE THAT.
STEVE CONTOUR NO COVERS FLORIDA
POLITICS FOR US AND JOINS US
NOW.
THERE WILL BE MANY WATCHING
THIS INTERNATIONALLY WHO DON'T
KNOW VERY MUCH ABOUT RON
DESANTIS.
PLEASE EXPLAIN WHY IT IS THAT
DONALD TRUMP MIGHT SEE HIM AS A
THREAT?
HENCE, PERHAPS, WHY HE IS USING
NICKNAMES TO MOCK SAID
CANDIDATE.
>> WELL RHONDA SCIENTISTS IS
SOMEONE WHO BECAME VERY POPULAR
AMONG REPUBLICANS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AT A TIME WHEN A LOT
OF THE COUNTRY WAS WALKING DOWN
THEIR ECONOMIES, REQUIRING
PEOPLE TO MASK, REQUIRING
PEOPLE TO GET BACK BE
VACCINATED, FLORIDA RESCUED ALL
THAT.
IT WAS VERY CONSEQUENTIAL
BECAUSE IT IS COUNTRY'S THIRD
LARGEST STATE.
DESANTIS BECAME A SORT OF
REPUBLICAN STAR IN THAT MOMENT
AND HAS, IN SOME WAYS, REACHED
THE PRESIDENTS POPULARITY
LEVELS WITH A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
DESANTIS IS SOMEONE WHO
ACTUALLY I WAS A BIT OF HIS
POLITICAL PAST AND STARDOM TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TRUMP ENDORSED HIM DURING A
VERY CONSEQUENTIAL PRIMARY IN
FLORIDA, HELPED HIM WIN THE
ELECTION IN 2018, AND NOW
DESANTIS, IN MANY WAYS, IS HIS
BIGGEST RIVAL GOING INTO A
POTENTIAL 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THAT
RELATIONSHIP FRAY IN THE PUBLIC
IN THESE CLOSING WEEKS OF THE
MIDTERM.
WE HAVE SEEN TRUMP CRITICIZING
DESANTIS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE HAVE SEEN DESANTIS ENDORSING
A CANDIDATE WHO IS VOCALLY ANTI
TRUMP.
THIS PAST WEEKEND, AS YOU SAID,
THERE WAS A RALLY TRUMP HAD IN
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE HE CALLED
DESANTIS RON DESANCTIMONIOUS.
NOT ONE WHO HIS CATCHER NAME
NAMES BUT NONETHELESS SOMETHING
HE TENDS TO DO WHEN HE SPOTS A
POLITICAL RIVAL EMERGING.
DESANTIS HELD EVENTS IN FLORIDA
SEPARATE FROM TRUMP IN FLORIDA
AS WELL WON BOTH CANDIDATES
WERE HERE, REALLY SHOWING THESE
GUYS IN A MOMENT WHEN PARTIES
TYPICALLY COME TOGETHER THERE'S
QUITE A WEDGE BETWEEN THEM MAY.
THIS IS ALL THROUGH 2024
POLITICS.